there was some backlash against SNL over
the weekend after they featured Nikki
Haley in a skit my question is why won't
you debate Nikki Haley oh my God it's
her the woman who was in charge of
security on January 6th it's Nancy
[Music]
bosi for the 100th time that is not
Nancy Pelosi it is Nikki Haley are you
doing okay Donald you might need a
mental competency test you know what I
did I took the test and I aced it okay
perfect score they said I'm 100% mantle
and you know I'm confident because I'm a
man that's why a woman should never run
our economy women are terrible with
money in fact a woman I know recently
asked me for $ 83.3 million there was
one leftwing activist who said that this
is comedy
washing so you know you've heard of the
white washing well this is comedy
washing and they're accusing SNL of
Comedy washing another conservative it's
more like cringe washing if anything